[Music]
going up well I feel demon are high
autism a guy just started telling but
like last year cuz I was like you know
what I'm gonna like people not knowing
about me everything just exploded
fast forward in my senior year I just
signed with d1 college I'm humbled
honored but same time I mean I'm still
Caitlyn
[Music]
once you look at this segment - you roll
out and I'm gonna tell you you know you
know I'm gonna tell you about this one I
said a dark that no I said I said I'm
that yeah I tell you this all the time
when you going when you do your 5 and 5
or 5 oh no you tear it down here yes sir
all these colleges they even know what
had autism until I said it
Kent State I wanted to come here cuz of
the culture in the basketball and the
people I had to make that known because
I don't want people to like me I'm just
like given something because of
something I have I recruited him because
I thought there was a chance for him to
be a really good basketball player the
fact that he has autism is the story for
him but at the same time he's a
basketball player who's trying to figure
out how to be the best college player he
can be the offers that everything I have
I completely earned I mean a lot of
people did not expect me to be here I
was born and raised in Little Rock
Arkansas I went to high school I love
our Christian Academy when people here
autism they don't understand why
sometimes they'll feel like that's an
insult that's not what it means at all
that means maybe there's somebody who
does things differently somebody who has
a hierarchy maybe if somebody who has
like sensory overload you never know
what that person is going through in the
inside because it autism meat also is an
inside struggle not a lot of people
understand it because they only see from
the outside I didn't find out officially
that Kaylin Edie autism until he was
about to
he wasn't focusing on me no sound at all
not even a cry and didn't want to be
touched at that young age I am what I
was for and I didn't talk to our 7
doctors they told me that it was a bunch
of Nevers never walk never talk wouldn't
go to regular school with regular
children if you say can't in front of
her she's gonna make sure she either
gonna prove me wrong or she is gonna
shut you down once you said that word
I'm sitting up there looking like yes he
will
mrs. Bennett you need to just come to
grips so I gripped my purse and I left
out my mom had a file about like my test
results
you know valuations and so like I was
looking at the first test score which is
super low just in the recent score which
is super high and I just broke down
crying because I was like look where I
came from Luke why I'm now I made sure
to celebrate an early birthday with the
people that's in Arkansas cuz like I'm
not gonna have most of the people here
all I ever wanted in my life was all my
family in one room this is just a just
an opportunity just thank all of you
like I know to celebrate me but this is
a chance for me to thank all of you
because there's no way that I would be
here without every single one of you
there's no way we're getting ready to
move to Ohio today we packed up the car
my mom's coming and we bout to move out
I'm asking that you would strengthen all
for my grandbabies God give them the
strength to be able to make this trip
God in the name of Jesus we pray amen
love y'all this is thousand miles away
from most of my family I have no idea
who these people are all he like knows
my teammates and my coach like there's
no one here I'm excited because like it
might not be like as many as
distractions to me as there would be in
Arkansas I think it's good for me to
being like a whole new surrounding a
whole new place and like a whole new
culture
I'm excited the biggest thing that that
drew me to him was his enthusiasm always
positive always bringing tremendous
energy and when you see that in a player
that that's really excites you as a
coach because you know they're a great
teammate here or two after I just start
talking I was like watching the game I
just like dad won't play basketball I
was like I don't think so cuz I hopes
the little boys they just kept trying to
you know bring him in and then I had to
stop myself because I was gonna put
limits on him
I thought about social skills because we
were his only friends
I was bullied because I wouldn't
understand stuff
he took me a minute to figure out like
this person is not my friend I'll be
getting bullied by I'll be laughing I
understand like hey can't you're being
bullied they were calling him the r-word
they're really just being really really
mean to him one day I went into his room
and he had like a built around his neck
hey sound just but I just believe but
his throat was sore I said mama I don't
like having autism I said more blunt
words I just took the hinges off the
door that was him tired of being bullied
and then she grabbed me in my face she
said do not hate it embrace it
do you really think that you the person
you are now
just because of one little thing I was
like no man she said be proud of who you
are I just had my first we could
practice a lot of you guys today there
was a noticeable execution improvement
today noticeable from just one day great
job
sometimes you see by myself because I
don't know a lot of people here I'm
still trying to get to know everybody
the biggest transition is being able to
just be yourself
just keep doing things don't impose do
you gotta find your own circle the
circle just won't come to you I'm trying
to recruit the best you know basketball
players with high character that would
represent Kent State the best way they
can and I saw that in Kaelin basketball
is his thing his platform is autism he
said people already know about it he's I
want them to accept us
the arts is a program I'm is Gina I met
her I was like beautiful awesome Oh
gross she said yes I top-10 the country
I say you know what I can do something
with this like I said what are your
goals he goes well I want to come to
college get an education because the
number two wanna play b-ball and number
three because I want to spread autism
awareness and help others like me here I
know like there's gonna be days like I'm
gonna be tired I'm gonna hate the world
about what those days I had heard a
whole lot of cancer in my life can't put
the period on it and after that nobody
tries those are days that's gonna push
you in those four days you can think
back on and be like hey I was in pain
but it was a day that I also got better
I've dreams I have goals and I'm gonna
do whatever I can to work towards those
goals
I love I love the people I'm around but
there's times where I gotta be in my own
little world
my mind goes crazy cuz I haven't liked
giving my brain a break or like I'm so
into what I'm doing that I forget like
as much as I want to who've I gotta take
care of myself first and foremost for
anybody else a lot of times after games
or like if I'm gonna large crowd of
people
I'd be like you go on hick I'm still
test up still getting myself back
together before I walk out that door
that's that's we overload
I say the bullets are flying and there's
a lot going on and I didn't use the word
sensory overload and he's looking around
saying what's going on here I'm gonna
tell you that that happens to a lot of
players okay
not just Kailyn but obviously with
Kailyn there's a reason it's happening
he processes some things differently we
have to physically show him
what to do ya need to watch this person
and see if they do right or wrong and
they do it wrong kinda would not do they
do it right I do this it was that thing
there's a lot more similarities to the
other guys on the roster than there are
differences in the Mac you got a you got
to have a bunch of guys that can play at
the high major level or you're not
winning like we have here so he's gonna
have to adjust to the physicality the
speed the intensity and that's just
that's all part of anybody coming into
this program everything has been turned
up ten times higher the speed ten times
higher attention to detail that's
probably the biggest transition I'm
still having a hard time with that just
taking something and being able to just
get that maintained in my mind it's just
moving on and making sure I do it again
there you go that's how every though
there are certain things that you feel
like you can teach and there's certain
things that you know either you have or
you don't have he's very hard to guard
one-on-one he can score over either
shoulder
he's got soft touch but he's also got
power something that's different with
Kailen you look at him you think he'll
be a rim level guy he actually has
really good burst and athletic ability
[Music]
he's working everyday he's seeing small
improvements every day and if he can
continue to do that
you know day after day we'll see great
things out of him I want to be on the AP
top ten I want to win that Player of the
Year I want to be like Zion when every
single war known to man somehow I can
achieve those goals there's no doubt in
my mind that I can achieve oh it's just
a matter of me having to work
[Applause]
I just looking here when I just smiling
like what is looking at home you know
I'm so far that's all six eleven of
their kid should I have autism
Brian bracelet I am bracelet any don't
matter who you are everybody has
greatness inside oh and I want to use
mine to inspire people make people smile
and be able to just show that hey my
name is Caitlin Bennett and I'm here
you're never alone
[Music]
great job this week
any questions for anyone there close
your eyes
image back there in the night
[Music]
it's good to be a man I went through a
whole bunch of stuff I got diagnosed
with ADHD a DD when I was a kid and a
lot of people's telling me I couldn't do
it either like that was I going too
small you didn't see that and even when
I got to college it was like yo he would
never be a pro you'll never play in the
NBA and I'm gonna play 14 years right
you always gonna have to keep proving
yourself you keep working to get better
go to court memc we all play us so check
it out let's go meet casa su casa your
story doc all the stuff you've been
through at such a young age to be able
to be with you right now
just everything man inspiring everybody
young guys and girls to be able to the
grind and work for stuff but you respond
people parents that got kids that don't
know you
that was the crazy part it's natural man
you've been you that's the best part
about it
we're coach me Mom there's gonna kidding
maybe out idea that I would break some
shoes right we're gonna write on the
shoes you go right up and you're gonna
pick the shoes and I'm aware I'm Tamar
in the game I'm a shy make the best
decision they are you won't know I'm
gonna say I'm gonna say B right
whirlpool knows because for one Reds my
favorite coat mine - that's crazy
yes story is super relatable to anybody
almost anybody that struggles in your
life to try to obtain a goal to have
that type of perseverance to be like you
know what I'm still gonna chase my dream
and do what I want to do I think it's
amazing I wrote two of them I say never
say can't and there's no such thing as
can't
oh that's fine do your signature on the
side so we know you know who did this I
got you yes sir good luck this season
keep working through these finals and
then go get buggies go do your thing
yeah you already know
you
[Music]